aujourd'hui Monsieur Laurent Janin
maître de conférence hors classe en
sciences de l'éducation à l'Université
de Cergy-Pontoise titulaire de la chair
de recherche ou l'architecture scolaire
transition 2 des espaces en transition à
la transition des espaces
je précise à votre attention monsieur
Janin que notre mission est composée de
23 sénateurs ça se voit pas tout à fait
ce soir mais
en général ils sont tous là elle a été
créée à l'initiative
c'est très fortement féminisé
elle a été réinitiative
du groupe rassolement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants madame
avait membre de ce groupe ici présente
on est la rapporteur
notre objectif est d'évaluer les besoins
de rénovation des écoles collèges et
lycées liés à la transition écologique
d'identifier les défis notamment
juridiques et financiers de cette
rénovation pour les collectivités
territoriales et d'évaluer
l'efficacité de la compagnement des
décideurs locaux s'agissant plus
particulièrement de l'accès à
l'information et à l'expertise notre
rapport assorti de recommandations
devrait être rendues publiques
en juin 2023 je rappelle que cette
audition donnera lieu à un compte rendu
écrit qui sera annexé à notre rapport et
que son enregistrement vidéo sera
accessible sur le site du Sénat monsieur
Jana nous avons besoin d'inscrire notre
réflexion dans une perspective
historique pour mieux comprendre les
enjeux actuels et futurs de la
rénovation des bâtiments scolaires je
vous remercie donc de vous être rendu
disponible pour partager avec nous votre
expertise je vous précise également de
je vous également le pardon de nous
avoir adressé des documents extrêmement
intéressants en amont de cette audition
ces documents ont été mis la disposition
des membres de la mission elle ne
manqueront pas d'éclairer notre
réflexion avant de vous donner la parole
pour présenter vos recherches notre
rapporteur Nadège avait va vous poser
une première série de questions je
rappelle que pour des raisons liées à
des contraintes des uns et des autres
nous devrons avoir fini l'audition pour
19h
merci d'avance
merci beaucoup monsieur Janin je
m'associe aux remerciements de monsieur
le Président et ça remarque sur
l'importance en fait de la mise en
perspective historique de notre sujet
donc j'ai toute une série de questions
juste j'accueille en accueil nos deux
collègues et du coup on est un peu plus
dans la parité parce qu'on plaisait en
fait juste avant que vous ne fassiez la
porte donc pouvez-vous nous rappeler les
grandes étapes de l'histoire de
l'architecture scolaire jusqu'à la
période récente y a-t-il un lien entre
la conception architecturale des écoles
collèges et lycées depuis de Jules Ferry
et la conception de l'enseignement en
d'autres termes en quoi l'architecture
scolaire est-elle le reflet d'une
conception de l'enseignement le cnesco
écrivait en 2017 dans un rapport sur la
qualité de vie à l'école que pour les
nouvelles constructions les décisions
intègrent davantage des considérations
environnementales esthétiques ou
financières que la manière dont le bâti
scolaire peut envisager les
apprentissages et le climat scolaire
êtes-vous d'accord avec ce constat et
d'après vous est-il toujours d'actualité
comment les exigences liées aux
nouvelles approches pédagogiques
influencent-elles aujourd'hui la
conception même des bâtiments scolaires
et je pense notamment au numérique mais
aussi aux besoins de locaux modulable
qui résulte par exemple de l'importance
du travail en petit groupe
quelle est la spécificité des bâtiments
scolaires conçus aujourd'hui en accord
avec les dernières normes
environnementales et on vient avec les
méthodes pédagogiques actuelles par
rapport au patrimoine scolaire hérité
des personnes des périodes antérieures
et pouvez-vous nous aborder plus
particulièrement la question des
activités physiques et sportives dans
l'architecture scolaire je vous remercie
monsieur le Président Madame la
remporterait les membres de la
commission merci de m'avoir permis de
pouvoir expliciter ces travaux de
recherche qui sont pas toujours faciles
à mettre en place puisqu'ils vont être
interdisciplinaires ils vont aborder
plusieurs champs de recherche le champ
de l'architecture le champ social mais
aussi le champ de la santé et au travers
de cette présentation que je vais faire
assez courte d'une quinzaine de minutes
je vais essayer de répondre à l'ensemble
de vos questions en apportant d'abord
tout un ensemble d'éléments un peu plus
un peu plus prégnant
évidemment et on le sait depuis pour
ceux qui se sont intéressés aux
problématiques pédagogiques et autres
depuis Freinet et depuis ses premiers
écrits en 1964
la question de l'architecture de
l'environnement scolaire et comment il
était configuré il était déjà posé comme
étant une norme importante
en termes aussi de
vision un peu plus internationale
Édouard maid qui était le responsable au
niveau anglais de toute l'architecture
des bâtiments scolaires anglo-saxons
évoquaient déjà des 1970 que le bâtiment
devait être un élément modulaire
adaptable flexible à des pédagogies
actives
alors nous on n'est pas restés non plus
sur notre est puisque 1973 dans l'état
français il y a ce qu'on appelle la
circulaire d'égout
qui explique que le bâtiment scolaire
devra être un bâtiment modulaire
flexible pour permettre des pédagogies
actives avec la possibilité de pouvoir
être en lien avec la nature et
l'environnement extérieur de l'école
ça vous aura pas échappé 1973 et en 1975
arrive la loi habi la loi des collèges
pour tous ce qui a conduit pendant
presque une quinzaine d'années à avoir
une massification donc on est passé dans
les années 1800 de la maison des écoles
où il y avait des établissements
scolaires qui étaient construit à partir
de petites maisons on est allé jusqu'à
Jules Ferry qui ensuite dès 1892 a
commencé à mettre en place les premières
bribes de l'architecture scolaire alors
je rappelle aussi souvent ce qui est en
1892 puisque c'est aussi intéressant de
se replonger dans cette histoire la
norme architecturale devait permettre
aux enfants de bien voir bien respirer
bien se déplacer dans un bâtiment qui
devait être garant de la santé des
enfants
ce qui nous a amené après à avoir des
courants hygiénistes ou pour travailler
contre la tuberculose on a eu des
espaces complètement ouverts parce que
la qualité de l'air était l'élément clé
de la tuberculose très bel exemple en
région parisienne avec une école
patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO à
Suresnes qui est une école qui est issue
de ce courant hygiéniste et il y a quand
même très belle très beau parallèle à
faire entre ce qui s'est passé au terme
de des courants hygiénistes et de la
nécessité d'ouvrir et de travailler la
qualité de l'air pour lutter contre la
tuberculose est-ce qu'on a pu vivre il y
a pas si longtemps que ça avec le covid
où il a fallu qu'on arrête les salles
d'établissement scolaires pour essayer
de lutter contre les propagations
donc tout cet ensemble d'architectures
scolaires on s'est retrouvé avec la loi
habi donc la loi Abi 1975 il faut
construire il faut construire parce que
d'un seul coup il faut accueillir tout
le monde
et donc là fort de tous les industriels
et architectes du moment il y a eu des
méthodologies constructives qui ont
permis de livrer des bâtiments scolaires
principalement sur base linéaire alors
ça va être un peu technique ce que je
vais vous dire mais vous allez vite
comprendre pourquoi sur ce qu'on appelle
des trames architecturales de 7 mètres
20 c'est-à-dire que c'est tout
démultiples de 7 mètres 20 les
établissements scolaires les classes les
couloirs
et en fait pourquoi c'est cette trame de
7m20 parce qu'en fait cette mètre 20
c'est ce qu'on pouvait mettre sur les
camions pour pouvoir les livrer les
matériaux pour pouvoir construire
rapidement puisque ça devait répondre à
une demande où on devait construire
rapidement
et donc on se retrouve avec tous ces
établissements scolaires qui ont une
même trame constructive donc des salles
dans saignement qui sont sur des bases
de facteurs de 7 mètres 20 donc on se
retrouve avec des salles à 40 et
quelques mètres carrés
voir 60 pour les plus onéreux on se
retrouve avec une empreinte foncière qui
est maîtrisée souvent dans des bâtiments
très linéaires avec du R+1 R+2 voir R +
4 en fonction de la densité
et donc on se retrouve complètement avec
toutes ces structures et ensuite on
arrive aux lois de décentralisation on
arrive à la prise en charge par des
collectivités des différents
établissements qui parfois des
établissements des études donc une
remise en place assez forte on voit dans
les années entre dans ces années 90
un impact assez fort c'est-à-dire une
prégnonce assez importante du geste
architectural témoin d'un passage d'un
an d'une empreinte forte sur un
territoire c'est à dire que et en plus
ça s'associe beaucoup avec l'évolution
des technologies sur les façades
la façade marque l'établissement
scolaire nouvellement dans les
compétences des collectivités devient un
objet aussi de politique locale et
marque sur un territoire
passé 90 on s'approche des années 2000
elle a les années 2000 se voit arriver
avec tout un ensemble d'artefacts dans
l'aménagement à l'intérieur on voit
poindre le numérique on voit comment
c'est à poindre des nouvelles pratiques
pédagogiques collectives c'est pratique
pédagogiques collectives qui étaient
déjà testées dans les années 60 par
freiner mais on les voit réapparaître
tout simplement parce que
il commence à avoir des tensions entre
l'établissement scolaire sa surface
foncière et ce qui s'y passe à
l'intérieur et donc on voit
parce qu'on l'avait déjà initié
à partir de du programme de Monsieur
Debré sur l'informatique pour tous on
voit là dans le numérique peut-être une
solution pour pallier à des manques à
des hérons ce qui commence à arriver à
l'école le fait de voir plus un
individualiser le parcours plus
s'occuper individuellement des élèves et
pas uniquement de la classe le numérique
était un objet qui était commandité qui
était vendus dans les années 2000 comme
étant quelque chose qui allait permettre
d'individualiser
vous avez pu vous en rendre compte et on
a tous vécu une période covid peut-être
avec des enfants des petits-enfants et
autres et vous avez pu voir que c'était
pas tout à fait prêt alors aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle
nous promet cette nouvelle chose
mais ce qui est intéressant quand moi
j'essaie de faire une synthèse avec mes
collègues il faut savoir que ce champ de
l'architecture scolaire est un champ qui
est pas qu'il est peu travaillé en fait
c'est qu'on n'est pas beaucoup dans le
monde à pouvoir le travailler parce
qu'il faut aborder des problématiques
transversaux il faut surtout accéder au
terrain et le terrain de l'architecture
scolaire n'est pas facile puisqu'il y a
des co-responsabilités des co-propriétés
des lieux des habitants des usages et
donc ça devient assez difficile et donc
il y a trois chair de recherche dans le
monde il y en a une en Australie qui
elle va principalement s'occuper des
modèles constructifs parce que pilotés
par l'État et piloter par Benjamin
Cleveland donc une au sein des colles
d'architecture donc il va pas qui eux
qui vont travailler à deux grands champs
le premier
les bâtiments éphémères qu'ils vont
devoir construire suite aux migrations
climatologiques
et les procédés constructifs la chair de
recherche scolar en au Canada elle
s'occupe principalement des écoles
maternelles élémentaires puisque le
Canada a 30 000 à rénover
nous plus humblement ce qu'on essaye
avec une approche au sein du laboratoire
bonheur et les collaborateurs c'est de
travailler sur principalement les
problématiques d'apprentissage et des
problématiques de relations sociales au
sein des espaces et quand avec nos
collègues on compare avec nos collègues
portugais italiens quand on regarde les
programmes quand on regarde les plans
puisqu'on commence aujourd'hui à avoir
avec des systèmes d'information
géographiques avec Google Earth et
d'autres outils de ce type là comment ça
pouvoir accéder à une géographie du
territoire et on commence à regarder et
si je devais juste résumer en un
transparent l'héritage aujourd'hui que
nous avons il serait en ces quatre
points là
la première chose c'est que toujours au
cours de l'histoire pour des problèmes
hygiénistes pour des problèmes de
massification pour des problèmes
sociétal pour des problématiques avec
des dès le premier programme
informatique de Monsieur Debré c'était
comment va être en capacité de former
des futurs ingénieurs en informatique et
donc il a fallu penser des salles
d'informatique je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de ces histoires des des
centres parfois des salles informatiques
qui étaient dans l'école parfois qui
étaient dans un CDI ou
un centre extérieur ou puis après ça
s'est arrêté puis maintenant on est
parti sur des classes mobiles depuis le
plan numérique François Hollande
on est toujours arrivé à questionner en
fait le bâtiment parce qu'il nous
contraint et on le sait depuis les
travaux les travaux d'Abraham mal ou de
Fisher dans les années 70 à 80 on sait
et vous l'avez vécu aussi on le vit tous
les jours l'environnement qui est autour
de nous nous contraint et les trames
constructives et ce qui s'est fait nous
a contraint dans notre pratique et donc
aujourd'hui et on le voit avec des
travaux de recherche les premiers
travaux de recherche multifactorielle
qui ont eu lieu ils ont eu lieu en 2015
par nos collègues anglais qui ont pu
accéder à 27 écoles à Londres et qui ont
fait des analyses pour la première fois
plus riches catégorielle c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont regardé la qualité de l'air
le confort thermique le confort
acoustique la mobilité de l'élève
et ils ont essayé de comparer ça avec
des classes témoins et tout la Batache
scientifique et en fait ils ont démontré
que ces facteurs environnementaux ont la
même prégnant ce statistique sur les
résultats scolaires que la catégorie CSP
des parents
c'est à dire qu'il y a autant de
puissance statistiques dans
l'environnement qu'on se dans lequel on
met en place l'enseignement et
l'apprentissage que l'influence
sociétale et l'influence que les parents
peuvent avoir dans l'enseignement ça ça
coûte permettait de confirmer pour la
première fois dans une analyse
multifactorielle ce qui se disait depuis
les années 70 mais qu'on avait du mal à
étudier de manière multifactorielle
au cours de l'histoire on sait toujours
trouver avec des bâtiments scolaires qui
étaient ce que moi j'appelle dans une
situation en équilibre précaire parce
qu'ils étaient soumis perturbuellement à
des tensions à des attractions alors
attention de population tension de
société tension de loi tension de
rénovation tension d'urbanisation et
puis attraction le numérique a été un
attracteur assez fort on est allé vers
le numérique j'en ai fait 10 ans pendant
10 ans de la recherche sur le numérique
où mes travaux montraient qu'au-delà de
l'expérimentation le passage à l'échelle
ne permettait pas de pouvoir reproduire
les résultats qu'on avait démontré dans
des laboratoires et que ça allait engagé
d'autres circonstances et le bâtiment en
était un
depuis les années 60 et depuis Freinet
qu'on enseigne d'ailleurs toujours à
l'École normale à l'UFM à l'sp à l'ISSP
donc tous les centres de formation qui
forment les enseignants on met en avant
ces pédagogies actifs freinaient
Montessori dit ouais et autres mais
quand ils font leur bassin
d'expérimentation ce qu'on appelle le
bassin de stage quand il s'expérimente
pour la première fois ils sont dans des
bâtiments scolaires où ils ne peuvent
pas le mettre en place
et donc on est dans une perspective de
flexibilité qui est promu
internationalement depuis les années 60
et même nous la France des 1973
mais qui se déplace difficilement
au-delà de la classe c'est à dire qu'on
va mettre des tables et des chaises on
va aménager sa salle de classe mais le
bâtiment en tant que tel c'est plus
compliqué de le travailler alors que on
sait que et les travaux de barrette et
d'autres travaux d'Anglo-Saxons qui eux
ont un pilotage un peu plus national de
cette recherche là soit en capacité de
nous dire aujourd'hui oui ça va avoir un
impact très fort donc on sort
difficilement de la classe et on le voit
globalement vous faites tous les salons
d'éducation aujourd'hui vous avez du
mobilier vous avez des tablettes vous
avez des choses mais on attaque jamais
la structure bâtimentaire la gestion des
flux l'emploi du temps alors qu'on sait
depuis les travaux 2008 des écossais qui
ont investi beaucoup dans la
transformation de la forme scolaire on
sait que l'emploi du temps va être
primordial c'est de transformer le
bâtiment c'est un nécessaire mais ce
sera pas suffisant pour transformer et
donc on se retrouve et ça ça a été
beaucoup dans dans l'intégralité de
l'histoire avec énormément d'acteurs là
je pourrais vous faire la liste des
acteurs qui interviennent dans le
bâtiments scolaire rien que les
institutionnels il y en a à peu près 15
corps institutionnels différents entre
les collectivités l'éducation nationale
les corps des marchés publics les corps
d'état je passe les opérateurs
aujourd'hui si vous regardez la banque
de territoire à un outil
pour travailler sur l'établissement
scolaire le cerema donc qui va dépendre
du ministère de l'Industrie à un outil
vous avez le ministère de l'écologie qui
a financer de des travaux de recherche
pour développer des outils sans
centralisation ça c'est une ça c'est une
constante depuis le début des années 60
beaucoup d'initiatives mais pas de
centralisation sans se poser la question
toujours mais un bâtiment scolaire dans
un territoire
c'est ce qu'on appelle nous en recherche
une contextualisation le bâtiment
scolaire qui peut avoir des
caractéristiques identiques
architecturales dans un village de
montagne n'aura pas du tout
la même
habitation la même occupation que le
bâtiment scolaire qui aura les mêmes
caractéristiques physiques en ville et
donc cette contextualisation voir c'est
ce qu'on appelle nous en recherche la
contextualité c'est à dire comment on va
discuter comment on va travailler dans
le bâtiment scolaire comment on va
enseigner comment on va travailler avec
les parents ça c'est rarement pris aussi
en charge alors de plus en plus dans les
collèges on parle de café des parents on
essaye de faire rentrer des parents dans
l'établissement mais ça s'arrête souvent
à une salle qui est en proximité du Hall
d'entrée et ça va s'arrêter là donc on
se retrouve vraiment avec quelque chose
de très permanent au fil du temps
et des pratiques qui restent encore très
contemporaines c'est-à-dire que si vous
listez par exemple je vais vous donner
un exemple la banque des territoires en
2017 à ouvrait a ouvert pour les
collectivités un préflash pour rénover
en termes de transition écologique leur
bâtiment scolaire
aucune information sur le site de qui en
a bénéficié comment quoi sur quel
objectif comment
la BU la Banque européenne
d'investissement qui s'associe avec la
Caisse des dépôts sur les actions de ce
type là aussi finance on ne sait pas
comment pourquoi
donc il y a toute un ensemble d'actions
chez les opérateurs
d'État chez aussi les collectivités avec
des exemples absolument fabuleux moi
j'ai la chance de pouvoir rencontrer des
collectivités et des rectorats qui
travaillent main dans la main
sur l'académie de Reims sur l'académie
de Lyon sur l'académie d'Amiens sur
l'académie de Paris avec des très
grandes difficultés parce que comment
chercher les outils les outils
législatifs les outils financiers les
outils pédagogiques les outils et on le
voit bien puisque sous l'impact
l'impulsion de François Hollande et son
plan numérique et sous la direction
Najat de valobel Kacem a été lancée une
réflexion sur l'architecture scolaire
qui a débouché aujourd'hui plusieurs
années à avoir des outils de l'éducation
nationale qui s'appelle archi classe et
avoir aussi une cellule Bathie scolaire
au niveau du ministère
des avancées mais pas de centralisation
ça c'est une constante
et quand on fait le point à
l'international cette fois-ci quand on
regarde avec nos collègues et qu'on se
dit mais qu'est-ce que va être le
bâtiment de demain en fait on retrouve
ces trois grands pôles le premier pôle
c'est que aujourd'hui un bâtiment
scolaire va être soumis à d'énormes
cycles alors je m'explique là-dessus
parce que c'est peut-être pas facile le
premier cycle macro c'est le cycle
bâtiment terre tous les 40 ans il a des
rénovations majeures des nouveaux
financements là on va passer sur des
normes techniques RT 2030 donc on sait
qu'on va devoir y passer des changements
climatologiques institutionnels par
exemple la réforme de la voie
professionnelle à un impact sur les
lycées pro
il va y avoir de l'innovation alors ça
c'est les collègues en économétrie
d'innovation qui en parlent mieux que
moi il y a trois cycles il y a un cycle
de juglard de kitchling en gros quand
une innovation arrive il faut 3-7 ans
pour qu'elle commence à arriver dans la
sphère publique je souvent je rappelle
cet exemple en 2016 un des groupes
scolaires les plus innovants qui étaient
le pôle muraux a été inauguré par Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem pour construire ce
bâtiment scolaire il a presque fallu six
ans à 7 ans de réflexion pour la
collectivité l'État et le rectorat quand
il a été pensé quand le concours
d'architecture a été mis en place
l'iPad n'existait pas et en 2016 au
moment où le bâtiment scolaire sortait
François Hollande inaugurait son plan
numérique d'un iPad dans des collèges
c'est à dire contre le moment où le
collège l'établissement scolaire et le
groupe scolaire a été pensé construit
par des architectes des programmes de la
collectivité on est allé chercher les
l'argent on affronte on a construit les
plans des outils technologiques
n'existaient pas quand il est sorti de
terre la politique de l'État était de
promouvoir ses outils technologiques
dans les espaces d'enseignement et donc
ces cycles d'innovation sont des sites
qui deviennent de plus en plus courts
avant d'aller ici que l'industrielle qui
était très long là maintenant trois ans
à 5 ans vous pouvez avoir quelque chose
qui va passer la sphère publique au sens
pardon public au sens général du terme
et qui va arriver dans l'espace scolaire
on le voit aujourd'hui avec
l'intelligence artificielle elle existe
ou la réalité virtuelle ça existe au
Mity depuis les années 90 ça n'a jamais
percé là actuellement c'est en train de
reprendre un peu du poil de la bête et
on commence à avoir des prémices de
choses qui vont arriver dans des écoles
et ça c'est boscovie dans moins de deux
ans
ça veut dire que évidemment ceci tout on
se retrouve avec des cycles qu'on
appelle des cycles méso chez nous alors
qu'est-ce que c'est que ces cycles
maison c'est tout simplement
l'enseignant qui a envie de faire des
choses tiens le mois prochain j'aimerais
bien aller à l'extérieur de la ville
pour pouvoir faire une visite scolaire
pour la revoir faire des choses ah mais
ah mince je suis embêté il faudrait un
grand espace mais j'ai pas de grand
espace dans mon établissement scolaire
est-ce que je peux le faire dans le
gymnase ben non il est partagé avec
l'équipe de volley qui vient de passer
en National 1 donc vous aurez pas la
possibilité de
ah et donc à partir du moment donné où
il veut exploiter le patrimoine mobilier
de son établissement de ce qu'il a
autour il est obligé d'avoir des
projections sur du sur du du long terme
pour lui mais qui est très court pour
les cycles des collectivités ou des
transformations d'urbanisme
et ensuite le micro alors le micro c'est
vous voyez c'est quand on arrive dans
une salle de classe il faut qu'on trouve
tous les objets disponibles pour qu'on
puisse organiser notre salle en îlot et
puis travailler et puis quand
l'enseignant s'en va il remet la salle
voilà et c'est un nouveau cycle qui
repart donc vous voyez que le bâtiment
scolaire va être soumis à des cycles qui
vont être excessivement longs avec des
pressions et des attracteurs terribles
et d'un côté avec ces usages il va être
aussi dans une cyclicité et évidemment
la différence entre des financements des
collectivités qui sont basées sur
l'année civile l'année scolaire qui elle
va être sur la structure éducative etc
tout cet ensemble de cycles mais le
bâtiment et aujourd'hui encore plus en
tension de par les événements sociétaux
qu'on vit que ce soit les transitions
que ce soit les évolutions
démographiques ou les collectivités ont
encore moins de vues sur les évolutions
démographiques à terme alors que parfois
pour quand il livre un bâtiment scolaire
elles se sont engagées pour plus de 40
ans
et donc nous on arrive aujourd'hui au
niveau international à se dire quand on
commence à analyser un peu tout ce qui
se passe dans plusieurs travaux de
recherche on se dit et là on le voit de
plus en plus un il faut que le bâtiment
soit en développement soutenable il faut
qu'il ait une architecture saine
sécurisante et bienveillante il faut
qu'ils retrouvent un aspect capacitant
flexible adaptatif et volutif et pérenne
dans le temps alors ça vous me direz
j'ai strictement strictement strictement
rien inventé c'est ce qui existe depuis
les années 70 et qui perdure dans tous
les pays alors certains arrivent à le
faire un peu mieux que nous d'autres le
font carrément moins bien mais tous
aujourd'hui s'accorde à dire que ce soit
des états que ce soit les guides par
exemple au Québec assortis un très bon
ouvrage sur leurs intentions éducatives
dans le bâtiment scolaire ça reprend ces
choses-là l'État français a fait de même
avec le bâti scolaire elle est
consultation multicadelle qu'il y a eu
nous moi j'aimerais juste qu'on puisse
ajouter des problématiques
physiologiques un peu plus fortes
par exemple la qualité de l'air c'est
bête à vous dire mais
un air confiné qui a beaucoup de CO2 et
on l'a vu un peu avec le covid vous
souvenez il faut aérer il faut dépasser
dès qu'il y a 1200 ppm il faut ouvrir
pour pas que le covid se circule en fait
dès qu'on dépasse 1200 ppm vous perdez
10 % de vos capacités cognitives à
résoudre des tâches complexes dès que
vous êtes au dessus de 1400 ppm il y a
un phénomène physiologique qui se passe
dans votre sens et ce qu'on appelle
l'acidose et qui va faire que vous
pouvez avoir des troubles les troubles
ils sont simples c'est mal de tête
anxiété un peu d'excitation sur la table
sur la chaise les Anglo-Saxons
aujourd'hui de plus en plus arrivent à
démontrer qu'il peut y avoir des des
relations causales entre la qualité de
l'air et l'environnement avec
l'acoustique elle absentéisme et les
taux d'arrêt maladie des enseignants
donc la qualité de l'air l'acoustique la
luminosité la colorimétrie la thermique
la température là maintenant vous voyez
bien que plus les années avancent plus
on commence à avoir des problèmes entre
est-ce qu'on va faire encore maintenant
le bac ou le brevet dans des situations
qui vont être compliquées on voit avec
les rapports de mes collègues du GIEC
qui va y avoir des zones assez
rapidement où il va y avoir des
événements flash de grande température
qui vont être difficiles à maîtriser ou
de très faible température et le lien
avec son appel la biophilie donc le
rapport à la nature donc ça c'est en sur
quoi et soumis le bâtiment et comment il
va devoir être en prenant en compte ces
problématiques physiologiques alors là
je vous ai probablement rien apporté de
plus que ce que vous savez par contre ça
c'est ce sur quoi on essaye nous à
l'international avec les collègues en
recherche avec nos états parfois avec
nos ministères d'essayer de discuter
pour dire donc c'est pour ça que je suis
absolument heureux de pouvoir être dans
cette commission pour pouvoir en parler
auprès d'une mission d'information
sénatoriale parce que c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire aujourd'hui pour l'État
français il y a aucune cartographie de
l'existant on a aucune idée de dans quel
état est le parc immobilier français
pour votre information c'est le plus
gros parc immobilier français celui de
l'école c'est plus de 150 millions de
mètres carrés dont nous estimations à
nous sont qu'en gros 60% devrait être
rénovés
si on fait juste de la rénovation
thermique c'est 40 milliards
donc et on sait que nous la rénovation
thermique est depuis 2018 on nous alerte
chez les collègues de la physico-chimie
de l'environnement puisque les bâtiments
individuels ou les bâtiments publics qui
ont été qui ont été rénovés vous savez
par la rénovation extérieure ils ont
gagné ils sont passés d'une énergie F à
une énergie A ou B mais en fait on
découvre que la qualité de l'air se
dégrade dans ces bâtiments et qu'il
arrive maintenant des problématiques de
santé tout simplement parce que le vieux
bâtiment qui avait pas de double fenêtre
avait une ventilation naturelle qui
permettait que le CO2 ne dépasse pas 800
à 1810 en moyenne et que dans les
nouveaux bâtiments intégralement rénovés
ou nouvellement construit s'il avait MC
a quelques difficultés on atteint un
minimum de 1200 ppm dès le matin
et donc on sait nous que ça va poser
problème à les collègues médecins savent
que à partir de 1400 ppm ça pose des
problèmes
donc on n'a pas de cartographie de
l'existant de ce qu'on appelle les
conditions scolaires on le voit avec ce
qui s'est passé au lycée
Aulnay-sous-Bois est-ce que il y a
encore des fils électriques du chauffage
est-ce qu'il y a des difficultés
fonctionnelles du bâtiment ou est-ce que
il y a des conditions sociales de
dégradation est-ce qu'il y a des
conditions on n'a pas de cartographie
alors qu'à l'heure du numérique
aujourd'hui ont certains pays sont en
train de faire ce qu'on appelle des
jumeaux numériques c'est à dire que ils
viennent
faire un plan numérique trois dimensions
du bâtiment scolaire ils ont construit
des bases de données pour pouvoir
travailler à la mutualisation d'achat
à une réflexion globale de rénovation à
une étude de quel serait les bâtiments
qui seraient les premiers à être faits
nous aujourd'hui on n'a pas ces outils
là et pour le moment la décentralisation
et le fait que chaque plan puisque
depuis le plan Vigipirate normalement
chaque plan devrait être numérisé dans
les départs dans les collectivités pour
permettre aux forces de l'ordre s'il y a
intrusion de pouvoir faire des
simulations de d'opération
on pourrait avoir ce cette base de
données sécurisées centralisée partager
avec le ministère de l'Intérieur et le
ministère de l'écologie le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et des
collectivités on pourrait avoir ce
travail là on l'a pas une centralisation
des initiatives une capitalisation un
partage des impacts
aujourd'hui on le voit bien que
on se retrouve très facilement sur une
volonté de performance énergétique et
c'est pour ça que je me suis permis une
petite fantaisie dans dans
l'antenne de mon PowerPoint que j'ai mis
une virgule après transition écologique
et j'ai mis des transitions parce qu'il
y a pas que celle-ci et en fait on est
souvent vers une recherche d'une
performance technique
de diminuer si vous regardez tous les
marchés globaux de performance qui
parfois les collectivités travaillent
avec on voit souvent que c'est - 26% de
consommation de chauffage moins 14% de
consommation d'eau par exemple il y a
rien sur l'air
rien
et puis quand un bâtiment est rénové
puisqu'il y a eu plein qui ont été
rénovés il y en a plein qui ont été
travaillés en fait il y a aucune
évaluation d'impact malgré des parfois
des financements d'État je rappelle
l'accord l'article 4 de l'accord de
Paris sur les évolutions climatologiques
qui normalement fait que l'État sur
fonds publics quand ils travaillent à
l'évolution du climat et d'évolution
doit devrait mettre ses données
d'évaluation d'impact en Open Data pour
les citoyens pour que les citoyens
puissent s'emparer de cette
problématique nous on recherche ce
serait également absolument intéressant
mais ce n'est pas fait non plus alors
que c'est fait en Belgique par exemple
mais c'est pas fait chez nous
il y a des programmes européens qui
partagent aujourd'hui des données sur la
qualité de l'air et la qualité
environnementale des établissements
scolaires ce programme s'appelle clean
hairschool vous avez à peu près tous les
pays européens sauf la France
donc une capitalisation et un partage
des impacts puisque là aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des acteurs que j'ai mis
rapidement les grands les grands États
collectivités opérateur recherche
industriels et professionnels
travail quelque part tous dans le même
sens mais aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile de pouvoir aller chercher de
l'information et de pouvoir la
concaténer et la comprendre
il y a aussi une problématique à
travailler qui est le cadre de l'action
publique alors
la gouvernance moi je suis pas
spécialiste mais je me dis qu'il là il
va y avoir un énorme chantier puisque on
n'aura pas l'argent de nos ambitions il
va devoir avoir un travail entre état
collectivités éducation nationale qui à
mon avis va devoir être fort en termes
de gouvernance en termes de pilotage
après opérationnel derrière on le voit
sur des plans Marseille on le voit sur
d'autres plans internes plus gobos où on
commence à mettre en place des
groupements d'intérêt public qui se
partagent des responsabilités les
financements on voit que sur des marchés
globaux de performance et on voit au
niveau européen il y a des programmes
comme énergie sprong par exemple c'est à
dire que la collectivité s'engage à
rénover énergétiquement le bâtiment la
banque prête et en fait l'industriel est
payée uniquement sur les 30% d'économie
d'énergie qu'il va réaliser donc il est
obligé de s'engager à les faire il est
obligé de les faire donc voilà des
nouvelles modalités de financement des
nouvelles modalités mais surtout ce qui
manque aujourd'hui c'est des
problématiques d'évaluation est-ce que
avoir rénové thermiquement le bâtiment
alors oui on va peut-être accéder à des
nouvelles performances énergétiques mais
est-ce que pour autant on en est
toujours arrivé à avoir des choses qui
permettent à ce que l'élève apprenne
mieux est-ce que sa santé soit pas
atteinte par exemple l'Allemagne attaque
des aujourd'hui des programmes
d'architecture scolaire ou la mise en
avant et la santé
et pour terminer les trois derniers
points c'est une échelle significative
c'est à dire qu'il a énormément
d'expérimentations très peu documentés
en France mais on n'est jamais passé à
l'échelle pour voir si les impacts et
c'est significatif aussi bien au niveau
de l'environnement qu'au niveau des
investissements qu'au niveau des impacts
pour le bien-être et l'apprentissage
on se retrouve à avoir vraiment se poser
la question de est-ce que c'est toujours
une école comme on la connaît
aujourd'hui puisque typiquement on voit
aujourd'hui des expérimentations qui
sont menées je pense par exemple à
Helsinki vous avez un établissement
scolaire qui n'a pas de mur mais qui
exploite l'intégralité des espaces qui
sont disponibles dans la ville
parce qu'il y a énormément d'espace qui
était libre et donc les élèves se
promènent ont des intercours de 8
minutes où il se promène dans la ville
d'entre d'une salle d'une salle de
théâtre où ils ont eu cours de français
en amphithéâtre en allant dans une
entreprise chimique où ils font un cours
de chimie on voit des nouveaux modèles
apparaître de ce type là parce que la
surdensité dans certaines villes ne
permet plus de construire non plus
comment réexploite donc il y a la
problématique d'un modèle matériel voire
immatériel sans mur physique mais aussi
virtuel ouvert et résilient et ensuite
ce qui est le plus flagrant aujourd'hui
au niveau international c'est comment
tous les états vont être en capacité de
franchir ce que l'Europe promeut et
valorise depuis longtemps ce qu'on
appelle avec le concept one el c'est une
école promotrice de santé vous l'avez
entendu parfois avec la cantine qui va
retravailler différemment mais en fait
on se rend compte nous que s'il y a pas
les éléments que j'expliquais tout à
l'heure sur les impacts physiologiques
et homéostasiques des corps la qualité
de l'air la mobilité le déplacement etc
ça va avoir peu d'impact et donc
aujourd'hui on voit poindre des pays
étran Gers voire européens qui
commencent à mettre des grandes
approches et des grands axes d'une école
promotrice de santé en appui de ce que
nous on a essayé de quantifier d'appeler
les EDF donc des environnements
dynamiques sains où on peut bouger où on
peut se déplacer et où la question de
l'enseignement n'est pas uniquement
circoncis à la question de la classe
parce que jusqu'à aujourd'hui on n'a
jamais re- questionné la classe on fait
toujours cours dans la classe et on fait
des évolutions et on fait des
innovations toujours en conservant le
système classe alors que chez nos
collègues étrangers aujourd'hui comment
à se poser de la question est-ce que la
classe du 19e siècle est encore la
classe et la structure pédagogique du
21e siècle et ça a un impact sur le
bâtiment
parce que dans les cloisons je vais être
très technique et la dernière minute par
exemple dans les cloisons des bâtiments
qui sont livrés dans certains pays il y
a plus d'éléments actifs il y a plus
d'électricité il y a plus d'eau il y a
plus de gaz tout simplement pour qu'on
puisse la bouger cette cloison donc les
éléments actifs deviennent dans les
façades dans les plafonds dans les sols
comme les hôpitaux qui sont nouvellement
livrés comme les industries qui sont
nouvellement livrées et c'est pour ça
que cette capitalisation pourrait aussi
intéresser ce que si vous prenez le
discours que je viens de vous tenir et
vous inviter un collègue de l'AP-HP qui
est en charge du nouveau bâtiment de la
Boissière à Paris vous allez voir que
vous enlevez parcours de santé et vous
mettez parcours élèves vous enlevez
hôpitaux vous mettez école on a presque
les mêmes discours nous l’hôpital de
demain et l'école de demain va avoir des
grandes similitudes sur sa construction
architecturale voilà j'ai essayé d'être
court et je pense que j'ai dépassé grave
erreur de ma part mais je suis
entièrement disponible à toutes vos
questions
vous allez pas être puni parce que vous
avez dépassé vous inquiétez pas je
voudrais juste revenir moi sur le
programme énergie Spong parce qu'on est
en a parlé la semaine dernière mais on
ne l'a pas présenté tout à fait tel que
vous nous l'avez présenté donc du coup
si vous pouvez revenir en quelques mots
je peux revenir alors l'origine
d'énergie spring et je pense que ce qui
est important c'est aussi de que je
prenne 30 secondes pour vous expliquer
l'origine de ce programme ce programme
il est issu des Pays-Bas clairement je
vais vous expliquer ce qui s'est passé
parce que ça peut être aussi informatif
au niveau des pouvoirs publics le
Pays-Bas a dit pour rénover nos HLM on
n'a pas l'argent
on n'a pas l'argent
mais on a des industriels intelligents
et qui vont pouvoir travailler ensemble
donc on va tous vous réunir autour d'une
table
et on va vous dire on va pas ouvrir le
50% des marchés sera pour vous société
d'État
par contre voici le deal vous avez 8
mois pour nous réfléchir à comment vous
allez rénover sur site occupé
en garantissant une diminution des
dépenses énergétiques de 30%
en permettant à ce que chaque habitant
de son de son comment de son appartement
rénové va pouvoir
rénover sa cuisine avec du matériel tout
dernier cri et vous allez donner une
enveloppe pour que la personne puisse
s'approprier ce nouvel espace
huit mois de travail les sociétés ont
proposé plusieurs scénarios et là l'état
dit ben nous on veut un mélange du a un
mélange du B un mélange du C
mais on va vous garantir que vous allez
avoir 50% du marché d'État pour rénover
les bâtiments les HLM dans ce sens-là et
en fait ça s'est passé comme ça
l'histoire après l'Europe a repris ça et
l'Europe adapte un peu puisqu’il parfois
il y a des marchés qui peuvent être
compliqués mais une des idées c'est et
qui revient aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on
appelle les marchés globaux de
performance c'est la collectivité va pas
forcément avoir le les reins solides
pour pouvoir tout prendre en charge mais
l'industrie si vous êtes en capacité de
rénover de manière intelligente alors
vous allez vous payer sur les économies
d'énergie qu'on va réussir à faire
il y a aujourd'hui
des programmes qu'on était extraits
d'énergie sprong et aujourd'hui ça
arrive
ça arrive en France et vous commencez à
avoir des sites Internet qui commencent
à en parler puisqu'il y a NRJ se
prendre.fr qui commence à exister en
parler vous commencez à avoir des grands
industriels alors je vais en citer trois
comme ça je vais pas me donc Léon Grosse
Bouygues Eiffage
il y a les industriels aujourd'hui qui
produisent du bâtiment et du bâtiment
scolaire du bâtiment public et du
bâtiment individuel et particulier qui
commence à travailler vraiment dans ces
problématiques de marché globaux de
performance ou si on en capacité
aujourd'hui de dire par le biais des
économies d'énergie que vous allez faire
nous on va pouvoir prendre une partie
parce qu'on va vous les garantir ces
économies d'énergie
donc nous on voit alors je suis pas
spécialiste et ces éléments là mais ce
que nous on voit apparaître c'est des
nouvelles modalités de partenariats
privés publics dans des contrats de
maintenance d'exploitation et de
financement
qui voit arriver en Europe mais pas que
en Europe je pense qu'il doit y avoir
des financements par exemple
d'établissements scolaire français par
des collectivités qui sont passées ou
qui commencent à passer par des
dispositifs de ce type là
merci de la précision
merci y a-t-il des questions
je vous en prie
c'était impressionnant ce que vous nous
avez dit moi j'étais enseignante
longtemps et ça fait du bien d'entendre
ce lien que vous faites entre les
pédagogies
et au fond quelque chose de très
matériel qui est la conception même des
écoles
ceci dit vous avez parlé beaucoup de la
qualité de l'air et à la commission
culture sur les bâtiments patrimoniaux
et les rénovations énergétiques on s'est
beaucoup interrogé justement sur les
diagnostics qui existent et qui sont
faits qui ne tiennent pas compte de ce
bâti ancien et qui préconise parfois
qu'on isole par l'extérieur un
massacrant les façades en justement de
tenant pas compte de cette respiration
donc est-ce qu'il faudra pas travailler
en premier lieu vraiment sur des
diagnostics qui parce qu'on tient compte
enfin on est obligé de tenir compte de
ces diagnostics et donc d'avoir une
rénovation qui au fond va contre le bâti
ancien et vous venez de m'expliquer que
ça va même contre les enfants qui sont
entre les murs puisque il y a pas cette
circulation qui se peut se faire parfois
par rapport à l'ensemble des bâtiments
scolaires qui existent alors actuelle
est-ce que vous voyez une différence
dans la dans le bâti dans la qualité du
bâti sur la période sur les bâtiments
qui ont été construits sous ferry par
rapport à ceux qui ont été pendant les
années 70
quelque chose qui me tracasse beaucoup
est-ce qu'il existe encore des des
établissements scolaires sur le modèle
Byron
voilà
et est-ce que vous estimez que les
spécificaires architecturales de chaque
période sont suffisamment prise en
compte dans les politiques de rénovation
énergétique menée à l'heure actuelle
merci
[Musique]
alors je vais vous je vais répondre à
trois ou trois grandes questions que
vous avez posées
j'ai focalisé et j'ai donné un exemple
de la qualité de l'air mais il n'y a pas
que ça en fait
dans le petit dossier complémentaire que
je vous ai donné il y a aussi des
problématiques sur la luminance les
degrés de lumière qui sont absolument
importants
on le voit par exemple arriver des des
grands écrans des tableaux blancs
interactifs et des choses ont vu
apparaître les
les rideaux
parce que la qualité d'une ampoule de
vidéoprojecteur ne sera pas capable à 90
degrés de pouvoir supporter un soleil
rasant ou un soleil levant
et donc on se retrouve nous à mesurer ce
qu'on appelle de l'aluminance
c'est-à-dire que les Lumières proche du
tableau et en fait les élèves qui sont
au fond on vont avoir ont excessivement
des grandes difficultés un laboratoire
de recherche qui s'appelle lutin avait
écrit un rapport en 2011 qui expliquait
qu'au-delà de 3 mètres les élèves à la
des difficultés de pouvoir lire des sur
des tableaux interactifs ou des grands
écrans si la police ne dépassait pas 28
polices 32 ou autre aucun enseignant
écrit dans ces dans ces supports une
police aussi énorme pour pouvoir
supporter donc il y a énormément de
variables toutes les variables
homéostasiques que j'ai je vais réussir
peut-être à faire ça voilà toutes les
problématiques de qualité de l'air on
sait que nous la tous les facteurs que
j'ai évoqués là la qualité de l'air
l'acoustique la lumière la colorimétrie
et la partie visuelle la thermique
l'hygrométrie donc la qualité d'humidité
et autres et la biophilie donc le
rapport à la nature soit visuel soit
existant dans sont des facteurs
déterminants alors il y en a qui sont
plus en moins prégnants il y en a sur
lequel on a les collègues
alors vous voyez la qualité de l'air ça
va être des médecins et ça va être des
physico-chimistes de l'environnement
donc il faut combler deux domaines de
recherche l'acoustique ça va être des
acousticiens des psycho-acousticiens la
luminosité donc là vous avez autant de
champs de recherche qui aujourd'hui
contrairement à mes collègues
anglo-saxons moi même j'ai encore jamais
réussi à pouvoir avoir l'ouverture dans
un établissement scolaire pour pouvoir
engager des recherches plurifactorielles
comme ça
c'est compliqué donc aujourd'hui on fait
état de ce qui se passe à l'étranger on
voit que quand on commence nous à mettre
des petits capteurs de qualité de l'air
puisque c'est assez facile et je le fais
avec des on le fait avec des élèves dans
des ateliers scientifiques ils le
construisent eux-mêmes ils le calibre
etc et on voit très rapidement que la
qualité de l'air augmente et quand on
fait des surventilations même naturelle
on voit que les élèves ont moins mal à
la tête donc mais on peut pas le
démontrer scientifiquement puisqu'on n'a
pas assez accès à ces terrains
l'acoustique c'est pareil ne pas
entendre dans une salle de classe ou
avoir des difficultés c'est très
compliqué le Brésil aujourd'hui
expérimente sur des tables en îlots que
l'enseignant est un petit micro et que
chaque petit enceinte augmente de plus
10 décibels ce qui est pas grand chose
mais en fait vous arrivez presque à plus
de voir plus trois points de moyenne
parce que les enfants on sait pas s'ils
entendent mieux ou si c'est plus clair
ou c'est plus audible mais on sait et on
les connaît ces éléments là donc sur la
qualité de l'air il y a évidemment pas
que ça par contre qu'on découvre nous
depuis 2018 par nos collègues qui sont
spécialistes en physique-chocythmie de
l'environnement et de l'air donc des
physiciens et des chimistes de l'air et
nous disent attention la sur le fait de
vouloir gagner absolument en énergie de
passer de eux ouf à a attention vous
construisez des des aquariums et ces
aquariums il y a pas de ventilation ou
très peu et même de la WMC permet
parfois pas de tout et donc il faut une
législation pour pouvoir le faire il
faut aussi comme il y a des indices
d'énergie il faut aussi des indices de
qualité de l'air on le voit bien avec
les askas qui évaluent la qualité de
l'air extérieur dans la qualité de l'air
intérieur il y a peu est-ce que je vois
des différences entre les établissements
ferrés les établissements d'aujourd'hui
oui est-ce qu'ils sont associés à des
procédés constructifs qui sont
contemporains oui est-ce que vous avez
encore du Pailleron oui
il y en a encore plein sur le territoire
quand on fait nous nos travaux de
recherche sur les 150 millions de mètres
carrés on estime aujourd'hui que pour
eux-mêmes aux normes pour enlever les
paillerons pour retravailler à des
carences fonctionnelles il y a plus de
60% du parc à rénover
et ensuite quand vous évoqué la
politique énergétique la politique
énergétique va avoir un impact
absolument important oui sur les
consommations à la gestion de nos
ressources et autres et la qualité de
l'air est-ce que j'évoquais là va avoir
de l'impact sur la santé et
si je peux me permettre ici je serai pas
taxé et de la performance scolaire au
sens large du terme quand on voit nos
collègues anglo-saxons nos collègues
également qui vont œuvrer nos collègues
canadiens italiens portugais qui vont
commencer à œuvrer sur des
environnements qui vont être plutôt
dynamiques c'est à dire des enfants qui
vont aller avec des mobilités douces
pour aller à l'école avec des
environnements qui vont être plus
ouverts avec
toute un ensemble d'une philosophie
anglo-saxonne qu'on appelle nudge qui va
permettre de solliciter les élèves
toujours au quotidien qui va travailler
sur les espaces qui qui font peur aux
élèves les sanitaires sont un facteur de
stretch chez les élèves et de problèmes
de santé publique pour moins national et
qui n'est très peu abordé
le fait de les couloirs de tous ses
collègues des années des années 70 ou
sous ses lycées qui font parfois 200
mètres de long qui sont parfois avec
deux rangées de classe et qui n'ont pas
de lumière naturelle sont excessivement
anxiogènes et dans le rapport du cneso
que vous évoquiez en 2017 c'est avec les
sanitaires
les premiers endroits de crainte et de
climat scolaire et de peur de
l'établissement scolaire
merci beaucoup avant de passer la
laisser la parole à Max moi j'ai une
question parce que vous êtes la
troisième personne que nous auditionnons
et ces troisièmes chiffres de mètres
carrés que différents que nous entendons
est-ce que vous dans le bâti scolaire
que vous évoquez est-ce que vous
intégrez s'agissant des lycées
l'internat les bâtiments de restauration
est-ce que vous intégrez le périscolaire
et parce que fréquence sache un peu de
quoi on parle de pouvoir périmètre un
peu précis quoi parce que si vous ne
parlez pas de la même chose on aura du
mal à faire un rapport alors
c'est toute la difficulté de la mesure
de ça parce qu'en fait il n'y a rien il
n'existent rien
voilà moi je vais vous dire exactement
comment je fais vous avez l'État
français et l'éducation nationale et un
des premiers à ouvrir certaines données
dans ce qu'on appelle l'Open Data et
vous avez un site qui s'appelle
l'automne Open
data.éducation.gouv.fr et vous avez
l'annuaire
que des bâtiments publics
crèche et col élémentaire école
maternelle école élémentaire collège
lycée généraux lycée public et technique
et vous avez là la coordonnée GPS
donc moi ce que j'ai fait c'est qu'on a
on a travaillé avec des collègues en
systèmes d'information géographique pour
essayer de faire une estimation de quel
était le parc puisque il n'y a comme je
vous disais en termes de d'observatoire
il n'y a rien alors
avec les hôpitaux quand on fait un peu
ce même travail on arrive avec des
collègues et on voit des autres
collègues par exemple ce qui avant a été
arrêté en 2019 par Jean-Michel Blanquer
qui était l'Observatoire de la sécurité
des établissements scolaires ils
estimaient à peu près à 140 150 millions
le public quand on met quand on met là
dedans les hôpitaux ou les on arrive à
250 millions dans les grandes peut-être
qu'à 20 millions de mètres carrés près
on doit pas être trop mal mais on n'a
rien on n'a rien pour le situer il y a
aucune donnée
ni public ni même quand on questionne
les collectivités autant que tel
c'est très difficile de pouvoir avoir le
métrage et ce qu'il y a donc nous on
utilise les outils en Open Data qui
existent les outils d'informes de
système d'information géographique et on
fait un travail de petite fourmis on va
faire de l'identification d'image on va
faire du mesurages on va et puis chaque
fois qu'on va dans un vrai établissement
chaque fois qu'un rectorat qu'une
collectivité nous invite et ben en fait
avec mon équipe ou moi-même on est avec
nos maîtres et puis on vérifie si on a
on a estimé à combien de mètres
différents la cour le bâtiment et ce
qu'on peut avoir accès à des plantes
mais pour le moment on fait de
l'artisanat oui
une observation personne n'a jamais
pensé à interroger à votre connaissance
des assureurs de ces collectivités qui
devraient avoir une vision assez parce
qu'ils sont comptables aussi
mais la difficulté qui déclare alors la
difficulté de ça c'est que nous on a par
exemple nous en recherche on a aucune
légitimité et eux ils ont aucune
ils vont pas nous les donner merci
[Musique]
réflexions que vous ouvrez comme
historiens j'ai quelques difficultés à
ce que vous avez dit sur l'impact de la
loi habille l'essentiel de la
massification a eu lieu quand même déjà
avant les CEG les biens
et le développement des collèges
uniformes et bilatéraux abîme on va pas
faire une querelle d'historienne sur le
sujet comme j'ai beaucoup de difficultés
avec ce que vous avez dit entre Kelly
qui a été longtemps en charge des
collèges dans ton département vous avez
parlé de multi-financeurs je sais mais
les connaître parce que moi mon conseil
général puis départemental il s'est payé
la totalité 100% des financements
concernant la rénovation la construction
de nouveaux collèges qui beaucoup de
financeurs pour les études je n'en doute
pas mais quand il s'agit de rénover de
construire les communes peuvent aller
chercher éventuellement des fonds d'État
à travers la dotr mais pour les conseils
généraux et pour les conseils régionaux
c'est 100% de financement de la
collectivité et quand on voit l'état
dans lequel se situer le parc scolaire
des lycées et des collèges dans les
collectivités à nos prix la charge
l'État est mal placé pour donner des
leçons et quand vous dites qu'on a pas
que les collectivités n'ont pas d'outils
de prévisions il a donc beaucoup plus il
me semble-t-il à travers de nombreuses
études qui peuvent commander aux agences
urbanistes par deux par exemple que
l'éducation nationale est convaincre
l'éducation nationale continue de manier
les quatre scolaire avec les règles et
calculer la Troisième République en
fermant les postes chaque année quel que
soit d'ailleurs les évolutions
prévisionnelles en matière d'habitat que
les élus distorrent les élus disposent
parfaitement je me demande quand même
aujourd'hui où se trouve ceux qui
cherchaient totalement la preuve dans la
prévision et de respect prospective et
ceux qui sont dans des gestion qui sont
bons la Quatrième République
une fois je vous ai dit ça j'ai envie de
porter la réflexion sur un point sur
différents
mais en oubliant de nous dire que la
plupart des systèmes européens sont des
systèmes soit décentralisés soit qui
n'ont même jamais été centralisés
où les provinces les cantons les
lendeurs les autonomies ils jouent un
rôle majeur
et la plupart de ces pays ont aussi des
autonomies d'établissements
considérables
il me semble que dans les réflexions
ça manque un petit peu parce que quand
on fait des composants avec notre
système hyper centralisé très
centralisée et où l'éducation nationale
comme un des éléments régaliens et les
pays avec lequel on compare il me semble
qu'il hiatus dans la comparaison parce
qu'on oublie de dire la grande autonomie
des établissements et que l'essentiel
des compétences scolaires sont des
compétences décentralisées voire même
qui ont peut-être jamais été centralisés
à l'État au niveau au niveau national
moi ce que je pense ce que vous voulez
de nous dire interroge beaucoup le
numérique l'a déjà fait les pédagogies
de plus en plus diversifiées le temps
est loin malgré notre régime jacobert ou
le chef de l'État pouvait regarder sa
montre et dire qu'elle à la même heure
dans tous les lycées de France le même
enseignement était produit de la même
manière dieu merci nous n'avons plus là
malgré la lourdeur de notre diabolisme
mais dans notre en effet les pédagogies
sont de plus en plus différenciées le
numérique est aussi bousculé
profondément cela et le travail que nous
allons devoir faire sur la transition
énergétique écologique et qui nous
préoccupe aujourd'hui
va encore bousculer tout cela donc moi
je me demande si le partage de la loi de
1982 est encore d'actualité si ce
partage
aux collectivités l'hôtellerie et la
restauration et l'immobilier et à l'état
la pédagogie ça fonctionne encore parce
que tout acte qu'on voulait très bien
dit tout acte immobilier est un acte
pédagogique et tout acte toute
équipement numérique est un acte
pédagogique tout alors quand on a vu une
pédagogie unique on pouvait un effet
fixer la taille des salles de classe ça
ne fonctionne plus le pédagogique vient
tout bousculer j'équipe donc je fais de
la pédagogie et si j'entre en effet dans
des concepts de transition écologique je
participe à la pédagogie donc je pense
que c'est notre loi de 1982 qui est
profondément interrogé ce partage qui
fonctionner peut-être encore en 1982
fonctionne-t-il encore
comme on n'ira pas vers
l'intestinalisation je ne rêve pas de la
pédagogie dans notre pays profondément
Jacobé on sera le dernier pays d'Europe
d'ailleurs à ne pas le faire
et bien il faut quand même construire
des bases d'un dialogue je pense que ce
que nous les travaux que nous aurons à
faire c'est de voir comment on dialogue
entre ceux qui paient et ce qui par
nature aurait tellement envie de faire
d'énormes dans tous les sens pour les
imposer à ceux qui paient
et je sais qu'au rue de Grenelle il y a
une envie qui démange de faire de la
norme donc il faut trouver le bon
équilibre le bon dialogue moi c'est
souvent dit au recteur comme responsable
de mes collègues dans mon département
mais dites-nous ce que vous souhaitez en
termes de pédagogie numérique à ce
moment là c'était le grand flou donc je
pense il y a un vrai dialogue en gros
questionnant le rôle de chacun mais en
arrêtant d'être dans une situation nous
fixons la norme et tu payes parce que ça
on connaît et ça marque bien la
décentralisation depuis 40 ans dans ce
pays
merci de m'avoir posé cette question
parce que c'est un sujet que j'avais pas
abordé du tout dans la présentation
et le partage des responsabilités et le
partage des des
tâches et ce que de ce qui incombe est
un sujet
absolument essentiel et on le voit se
frotter aujourd'hui de façon très
difficile entre ceux qui habitent le
lieu et ceux qui payent les factures du
lieu si je le résume ainsi
et
sous ce mandat politique il y a pour la
première fois de l'histoire de la
Cinquième République en éducation un
programme qui s'appelle
les l'IFS donc un investir un plan
d'investissement sur la forme scolaire
qui a été mis sur lequel a été mis 250
millions d'euros sur le plan de relance
au dessus sur la table pour justement
évoquer ce que vous êtes en train de
dire c'est à dire une de travailler sur
les alliances territoriales et de se
dire OK
collectivité
rectorat et en gros il y a une
triangulaire autour de la table voire
plus mais il y a une triangulaire de
base collectivité rectorat
acteur associatif acteur périscolaire
acteurs autres vous êtes
communauté éducative au sens très large
et puis derrière c'est un laboratoire de
recherche qui doit évaluer ce qui se
passe et l'impact de ce qui s'est passé
on est vraiment au prémices puisque le
premier
l'appel à manifestation d'intérêt s'est
terminée il y a eu deux appels le
premier à apporter huit lauréats
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir être dans
partie des consortiums qui ont été
lauréat et donc travaillons aujourd'hui
dans cette interstice où il y a et vous
avez raison absolument
d'abord déjà une balise explications de
texte mais comprendre quel est le
langage de chacun et de comprendre
quelle va être l'impact de chacun un
investissement comme vous évoquiez dans
la collectivité et parfois des collègues
d'enseignants qui disaient mais l'archi
la collectivité a mal fait non vous
comprenez pas comment le système
fonctionne aujourd'hui les
programmations les schémas de
programmation les schémas de marchés
publics parfois les schémas de
d'occupation des lieux par les
enseignants les schémas aussi de de
postes de circulation des postes les
projets éducatifs les transformations
que l'État demande aux collectivités
autre le numérique qui est venu
bousculer et les les plans numériques
François Hollande avec les tablettes
dans les collèges à assez facilement et
assez fortement bousculé ces éléments là
et je suis d'accord avec vous il manque
cet espace et ce média de dialogue
et qui je l'espère au travers du plan là
sur la forme scolaire donc premier appel
terminé deuxième appel ce qui auront la
chance d'aller à l'oral pour se faire
sélectionner vont se connaître au mois
de mars et on connaîtra au mois de juin
les nouveaux leaders et donc il y a il y
aura sur le territoire
plusieurs
expérimentations d'alliances
territoriale nouvelle Sam moi j'en suis
très heureux
là où ça m'embête un peu plus moi je
vais un peu pareil je pense qu'on je
vais aussi dans votre sens moi ce qui
m'embête un peu plus c'est comment on va
évaluer l'impact et comment va être en
capacité de dupliquer ou pas de prendre
en compte des bonnes pratiques ou des
mauvaises pratiques de ce qui s'est
passé dans ces alliances territoriales
ce que les collectivités il y a des
collectivités le rectorat il y en a qui
joue le jeu et qui sont d'accord comme
vous le disiez main dans la main
donnant-donnant je veux bien investir
mais quel est votre pédagogie et
inversement je veux bien développer des
pédagogies qui vont permettre de faire
des retours à l'emploi ou du bilinguisme
ou autre sur un territoire et comment je
le travaille
on le voit cette question a été
bouleversée ensuite par le covid ce qui
a permis d'ouvrir plus rapidement
piloté par France 2030 et donc je pense
que ça va être très intéressant de
pouvoir observer voir même dans la
commission questionnée les collectivités
territoriales qui se sont engagées dans
ces programmes sur la forme scolaire
pourquoi ils y sont allés comment ils y
sont allés puisque là ça fait partie de
l'ADN de ce programme d'être dans le
dialogue de la répartition de
responsabilité
et d'action et ensuite ce qui va être
intéressant c'est de voir par le
pilotage par France 2030 comment
l'évaluation en surplomb de
l'intégralité des dépenses de ces 250
millions vont être des choses qui vont
permettre d'alimenter la réflexion que
et la question que vous venez de me
poser dans laquelle pour le moment je
peux juste vous répondre que
il y a des programmes
je pourrais vous en donner la liste et
les officiels sur sur à l'éducation
nationale et sur le site de France 2030
il y a déjà 7 lauréats du premier les
prochains seront au mois de connus je
pense au mois de juin et je pense que
c'est ce travail là qui va falloir
regarder à la loupe pour pouvoir
apporter des éléments de réponse parce
que ça c'est pas ma spécialité dans les
rapports états collectivité moi ce qui
m'intéresse de voir c'est est-ce que une
fois ce nouveau rapport installé et une
transformation effective avec tout le
monde d'accord est-ce que ça va
réellement avoir un impact sur les
apprentissages et les éléments de
performance scolaire
donc je vous apporte pas une vraie
réponse mais je vous apporte un élément
peut-être qui que qui est dans le
spectre aujourd'hui des programmes de
recherche développement et d'analyses
territoriaux c'est ces programmes sur la
forme scolaire et les 250 millions qui
sont été mis pour ces programmes par le
biais de l'exécutif sur du plan de
relance pour travailler sur ces
nouvelles alliances territoriales
pour résumer
vous avez évoqué toutes les interactions
c'est à dire que il faut prendre
l'environnement global de du bâtiment
scolaire au même niveau que la CSP parce
que ça a autant d'influence faut prendre
en compte
les volontés pédagogiques enfin je vous
refais pas je le ferai surtout moins
bien que vous ne l'avez fait le panorama
que vous nous avez décrit
tout en répondant
au circulaire ou décret ministériel qui
nous demande qui demande aux
collectivités plus exactement d'avoir
rénové et d'avoir investi 40 milliards
d'ici 2030 c'est-à-dire demain matin
pour diminuer de 40 % les gaz enfin les
émissions de gaz et effet de serre et de
60 pour 2050 c'est-à-dire après demain
matin alors que nous n'avons même pas de
cartographie de l'existant c'est ça la
réalité donc j'ose pas vous demander si
vous deviez faire si j'étais président
de la région au hasard Normandie que je
devais construire un lycée en vallée de
l'heure parce que actuellement les
jeunes ils font deux heures de car pour
aller au lycée le plus proche et que je
vous demandais de faire le programme de
ce lycée je suis sûr que vous y
arriveriez mais en tout cas moi je n'y
arrive pas et je pense que on risque de
se jeter sur une rénovation énergétique
parce qu'on nous dit que et je suis pas
une climatoseptique s'il y a vraiment
des urgences on nous dit qu'il faut
faire ça très vite sans avoir vraiment
envisager la globalité du problème et y
compris en
pouvant nous dire dans quelques années
ah bah c'est super on a fait une belle
enveloppe bien hermétique mais nos
gamins ils respirent super mal dedans et
ils ont mal au crâne au bout de deux
heures de cours quoi
[Musique]
donc en fait
oui et non
parce qu'aujourd'hui je trouve qu'il
peut y avoir des outils d'État et je
peux je trouve qu'il peut y avoir des
expérimentations extérieures que un état
comme le nôtre pourrait se permettre
mais qui va falloir oser
premier exemple
l'approche chilienne de l'architecture
élémental qu'est-ce que c'est c'est de
livrer
un bâtiment public
pas forcément terminé
et que au moment où on coupe le cordon
il est tous les éléments dans un accord
plurilatéral pour savoir tout ce qui est
bien dedans tout ce qui est sécuritaire
etc
n'empêche que les cloisons l'occupation
d'espace etc n'est pas terminée et en
fait c'est par les usages que commencent
à se déterminer comment on s'approprie
le lieu
il y a d'autres outils législatives dans
l'état français le permis de faire
responsable de collectivité vous
connaissez ce petit objet qui est le
permis de faire c'est que quand vous
livrez un bâtiment qui doit avoir
l'accessibilité pour des personnes en
situation handicap vous avez le droit
pendant les deux premières années à ne
pas le livrer terminer et qui puisse
être testé par des personnes en
situation de handicap
ce qui moi me pose le plus problème et
qui va vous poser le plus problème en
collectivité
c'est que vous allez devoir investir sur
40 ans des transformations rénovation
énergétiques qui vont être importantes
sans avoir derrière
la
d'abord la garantie que ce bâtiment va
correspondre aux besoins dans 20 ans en
terme de démographie et autres
le niveau de la connaissance
scientifique aujourd'hui est assez
pluricatorielle et on ne peut pas
uniquement se centrer sur des
problématiques d'énergie même si elles
sont très importantes en termes de
d'épuisement des ressources des coûts
indirects indirects etc là on est
d'accord mais derrière
créer des aquariums pour diminuer
l'effet peu à terme
avoir des impacts qu'on ne peut pas
encore mesurer aujourd'hui quand votre
collègue me posait la question des
paillerons quand on a conçu des
paillerons c'était le meilleur c'était
la meilleure réponse industrielle du
moment
c'est exactement ce que tous les
industriels dans la pression qui était
dans ce qui était fait c'était ça
faisait partie des meilleures réponses
industrielles
là aujourd'hui on est on est dans des
perspectives qui ont été exactement
les mêmes
et vous évoquiez un lycée et moi je vais
rebondir aussi sur la question de
Monsieur je vais aller un peu plus loin
quand je vous parlais de l'exemple
d'Helsinki et ce qui se passe c'est nos
pays nordiques
la question de la responsabilité est à
collectivité elle est posée mais les
pays nordiques vont un peu plus loin
disant est-ce qu'on pourrait pas poser
la question du patrimoine mobilier
public dans son ensemble
c'est à dire que le collège le lycée
l'école élémentaire maternel c'est tout
un même ensemble
avec parfois des responsabilités qui ne
sont plus ni à la mairie ni au
département ni à la région si je fais le
parallèle
et donc peut-être que ce lycée que vous
devriez construire assez rapidement
peut-être qu'il peut être aussi
repartagé avec des collègues d'un
collège autre qui peut être transformé
et que une analyse de l'existant au
niveau des bâtiments publics seraient
absolument assez essentiel
donc ou alors je serai embêté oui et non
puisque je ferai comme les collègues
quelque part qui construisent
aujourd'hui des industries qu'ils
appellent des entreprises ou des
industries du futur ou alors les
hôpitaux du futur en fait je ferai une
architecture absolument modulaire sur
des définitions architecturales
poteaupoutres c'est-à-dire que c'est le
sol qui est porteur le plafond les
éléments techniques dans les façades ou
alors au plafond
avec
la volonté d'une gestion des ressources
les plus maîtrisées possible avec
l'outil qu'on appelle la GTB la gestion
technique de bâtiments et que je
partagerai avec l'intégralité des
citoyens et des autres membres de la
collectivité départements réunis
et puis en disant dans l'état de la
connaissance et dans l'état industriel
je peux faire ça aujourd'hui
la seule chose dont on est sûr c'est que
pour faire des pédagogies actives aux
nouvelles comme évoquées monsieur avec
le numérique ou pas le numérique
l'arrivée des groupes comme évoquait
madame dans les questions etc la
persistance qu'il y a c'est qu'il faut
plus de mètres carrés
c'est à dire que quand vous avez 30
élèves en rang d'autobus dans une salle
de classe de 50 mètres carrés que vous
commencez à faire des groupes en fait
l'empreinte foncière des élèves et des
groupes est plus grandes et donc ils
vont devoir sortir et d'aller parfois
dans les couloirs ce que les angles les
anglo-saxons sont en train d'investiguer
parce qu'ils appellent de learning
corridor qui commence à voir le couloir
va devenir un espace d'apprentissage
merci si vous pouviez avoir à des
réponses un tout petit peu plus courtes
parce que on n'ira pas au terme de des
demandes des uns des autres il y a une
question
pas la question mais mais
la dichotomie qui est l'effet de la
décentralisation entre l'éducation
nationale donc l'État et les
collectivités qui a tous les niveaux
posent de très gros pôles on l'a vu au
moment du covid tu disais tout à l'heure
on a de très gros problèmes il y a
incontestablement
de la part de l'État la volonté de
continuer à gérer ces établissements
mais comme il a seulement les services
de l'éducation et que la collectivité a
les services de qui doivent permettre de
faire fonctionner
les cuisines l'entretien etc on a des
problèmes
permanents donc je crois que ce sera
dans dans notre dans notre réflexion ça
sera sans doute un élément premier à
aborder ensuite sur
l'état de ce qui doit être refait je
prends l'exemple de mon département il y
a 36 collèges publics il y a quelques
une dizaine de collèges privés mais on
pourra en discuter à un autre moment
mais sur le sur le collège public
il y a des bâtiments qui n'ont aucune
homogénéité c'est-à-dire que on a des
bâtiments qu'on a repris soit sur
d'anciennes écoles soit comme chez moi
sur ce qui était autrefois l'école
normale d'instituteurs et il y a
aucunegalité et là je me pose la
question est-ce que à un moment donné
pour arriver pour
pouvoir répondre au pari qui nous est
qui nous est donnée et ce qu'il faut pas
faire plus autre chose que de reprendre
l'existant ou même de construire du 9
mai de façon
différente sur chaque endroit et ce
qu'il y a pas un système modulaire qui
permettrait dans une logique beaucoup
plus pragmatique et ça coûterait à mon
avis beaucoup moins cher de trouver des
terrains et de mettre des
collèges ou des lycées sur des terrains
neufs et je sais que c'est très
difficile parce que dans chaque
collectivité concernée il y a un
attachement à tel ou tel établissement
au lieu au centre-ville etc et donc je
dis qu'on a là un pari qui me paraît
aujourd'hui au moment où je vous parle
très difficile à réaliser
la réponse va être excessivement courte
cette fois-ci
parce que l'empreinte et l'analyse de
l'empreinte foncière territoriale dans
une perspective de patrimoine immobilier
tel que vous l'évoquiez
bah oui moi je suis partant je peux
venir dans votre département et parce
que ça fait partie des pistes de
réflexion que nous avons nous en
recherche pour pouvoir
peut-être harmoniser peut-être plus
performé peut-être réfléchir à d'autres
typologies d'usage parce que derrière ça
va être ça aussi un bâtiment scolaire
qui peut être ouvert 200 jours à l'année
va poser des questions dans des
empreintes foncières sous tension dans
des densités absolument fortes
là l'expérimentation de Helsinki ou du
jour au lendemain vous devez fermer un
lycée 2000 2000 élèves et que vous avez
pas de place vous avez pas de place pour
pouvoir en construire il faut pouvoir
vous pouvez pas les reloger dans
d'autres établissements scolaires donc
il faut repenser les migrations
climatologiques que mes collègues
australiens vivent ou d'un seul coup ils
se retrouvent avec des migrations de
population en 5-7 ans
et que il va falloir accueillir et puis
ils me disent mais Laurent peut-être que
dans 15 ans ces personnes-là seront
parties et donc qu'est-ce que je fais de
mon bâtiment des collègues de conseil
départemental de La Rochelle ou des
Landes avec qui je discutais me disait
Laurent on fait on vient plus à la
retraite dans La Rochelle et les Landes
on fait moins de bébés donc j'ai une
difficulté pour les collèges
pardon et donc les collègues me disaient
Laurent est-ce qu'on peut imaginer des
éléments modulaires comme vous évoquez
pour pouvoir répondre à des éléments de
transition démographique sur des
périodes laquelle donc on commence à
réfléchir avec eux on voit que des
périodes de 7 à 10 ans sont des périodes
qui peuvent avoir une certaine cohérence
en associant le patrimoine immobilier
sur le terrain mais c'est des choses
voyez
on est d'accord on est mais c'est pour
ça que la sectorisation c'est pour ça
que j'évoquais cette question là de la
cartographie de l'existant en
envisageant la problématique d'un
patrimoine immobilier en envisageant des
problématiques de flux on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la RT 2030 va dire
attention tous les bâtiments publics qui
sont à plus à moins de 700 mètres d'un
axe routier fort de pollution extérieure
va devoir avoir peut-être du triple
vitrage et des choses de ce type là
dans les forces dans les zones à forte
densité le triple vitrage va on va pas
le mettre à tous les établissements
scolaires ça va devenir donc là moi bien
sûr que je vais dans ce sens là et au
contraire
moi ce qui m'intéresse dans mes
programmes de recherche c'est justement
ce lien entre le bâti qui existe et que
vous collectivités par le biais de
l'éducation nationale je l'espère un
jour va va pouvoir être dans ces
éléments de réflexion forte et je pense
que le programme sur la forme scolaire
va être atteint un élément pour
alimenter vos réflexions mais pour le
rapport de joint ce sera loin d'être
terminé mais au moins certaines
collectivités invitées pour voir ce
travail là ça je pense que ça va être
essentiel
la problématique moi si j'évoquais des
grandes problématiques c'est la
problématique de la rénovation de la
construction qui va être absolument à se
poser la question comment rénove et
comment on retranforme des choses
existantes
est-ce qu'on rénove où est-ce qu'on rase
là dessus je suis d'accord avec vous la
question de des modèles constructifs
nouveaux et du déplacement parfois
d'établissements scolaires plus
peut-être en périphérie avec un nouveau
système de transport scolaire on le voit
nous aussi arriver on voit arriver des
toutes ces questions là c'est des
questions que dans le dialogue entre
état collectivité et rectorat parce que
je mets état financeur enfin un
collectivité rectorat je mets quelque
part ce triple ce triangle là va devoir
être fait en prenant en compte peut-être
des petites choses que aujourd'hui la
recherche on a réussi à démontrer avec
des éléments qui des petites sonnettes
d'alerte et sur lequel on peut
travailler ensemble
j'ai construit ça en 2017 en tant que
mère j'ai construit une cantine scolaire
entièrement en bois isolation paille
certes aujourd'hui on ne la chauffe pas
donc c'est extraordinaire sauf qu'elle
est tellement bien isolée il a fallu
justement que je fasse se mettre un
récupération d'air pour que ça puisse
surtout l'été l'hiver encore ça va mais
l'été c'était intenable donc moi je me
pose cette question là on paye quand
même des architectes
normalement ils sont là pour nous
conseiller
généralement on leur fait confiance donc
je trouve quand même assez curieux qui
n'est pas pensé que fallait mettre un
récupérateur d'air justement pour faire
circuler l'air puisque la cantine est
tellement bien isolée je vous dis moi
aujourd'hui ça chauffe pas cette cantine
en plein hiver c'est extraordinaire en
plus avec des matériaux je dirais noble
la paille le bois voilà donc c'est
extraordinaire j'avais tous les maires
du coin qui venait la visiter
qu'aujourd'hui je leur dis attention si
vous construisez avec ce genre de
matériaux
faites attention qu'il y a une bonne
circulation d'air parce que en effet
vous l'avez souligné ça peut être aussi
un problème voilà donc je voulais juste
savoir la dedans les architectes
quelles responsabilités ils ont comme
elle a été courte tu rajoutes un élément
juste parce que Jacques assez que le
financement ça sera un des éléments
déterminant de la réussite de cette
mission ou pas comme d'ailleurs dans
bien d'autres domaines je veux savoir ce
que vous pensiez vous
du Partenariat Public Privé parce que je
me souviens d'une époque où ce
partenariat avait mauvaise presse parce
que quantité de régions notamment qui
avait construit des lycées avec en
recourant à ce dispositif l'avait
regretté puisque les conditions étaient
totalement déséquilibrées au détriment
des collectivités ce que vous avez
plutôt une image positive de ce de cette
possibilité
[Musique]
donc
ça c'est
c'est un peu ce sera posé la question à
l'ordre des archives que ça moi je peux
pas y répondre mais je vois bien la
difficulté quand je travaille avec des
architectes et des collectivités à
pouvoir modéliser réellement l'Efficient
sur du cours du Moyen du long terme dans
des modèles mathématiques qui doivent
être maintenant aujourd'hui tellement
précis tellement tellement fin qui
n'était pas demandé encore 20 ans de ça
et que et que c'est aussi une transition
numérique eux qu'ils doivent avoir au
sens modélisation des données et
modèles de plus en plus performant pour
analyser et anticiper qui à mon avis ne
doit pas être un métier facile mais ça
je comprends et ensuite pour répondre à
la question sur les PPP
c'est comme tout un contrat en fait
c'est la définition même des clauses du
contrat qui sont importantes et dans les
PPP qui ont pu être passé il y a des
années et un des exemples et le plus
flagrant sur le ministère de la Défense
je crois ou le PPP était un peu fou je
crois aujourd'hui que les industriels
revoir aussi leurs problématiques de PPP
par le biais de marché globaux de
performance qui sont justement des
approches qui pourraient permettre de
refaire des problématiques privées
publiques et de toute manière enfin moi
en tant que citoyen
averti sur ces questions là je ne sais
pas comment se financera par l'État en
tant que tel l'État au sens très large
d'une herbe aux collectivités compris
toutes les transformations et la gestion
des transitions qui vont être à venir
donc
va passer obligatoirement une
problématique de marché public et je le
vois bien dans par exemple si vous
prenez le document de le pesque
de novembre 2022 sur les rénovations
énergétiques qui dit clairement qu'il
faut modifier les marchés publics par
exemple
parce que ça va être difficilement
tenable
pour les collectivités